1900 euros pour ce très bon gros à 1900
cellule nagisa 1900 milles sans savoir
que l'on est content c'était en février
dernier à besançon le côté pile d'une
vente aux enchères
celui où le commissaire priseur est dans
la lumière et se livre à un exercice de
style
et puis il ya le côté face celui du
temps des expertises
elles peuvent être judiciaire à la
demande d'un tribunal ou volontaire à la
demande de particuliers comme ici dans
le cadre de la liquidation d'une
succession en fait on travaille là ça va
être par exemple pour un meuble comme ça
qu'un meuble très classique
ça va être bon j'ai déjà fait un juste
un petit inventaire très très succinct
ou jimmy simplement armoires ancien n'y
en a qu'une dans la pièce donc on ne
peut pas la confondre
mais là maintenant que c'est avant tout
que je fasse une vraie description de
catalogue
c'est à dire que je dise bon cette
armoire et les anciennes mais il ya eu
des choses de refaite la corniche voyez
la corniche de la corniche d'origine
donc c'est quand même à préciser aux
acheteurs même si aujourd'hui c'est un
meuble qui vaut 150 200 euros dans cet
appartement dont le propriétaire est
décédé il faut évaluer ce que les
héritiers ne souhaite pas conserver une
multitude de meubles et d'objets d'art
qui seront vendus aux enchères
l'inventaire va prendre quelques jours
car l'occupant des lieux était un
collectionneur acharné
enfin c'est un très très beau mouvement
18e
autre décor autre mission ici c'est une
vente judiciaire que notre commissaire
priseur est en train de préparer
elle aura lieu sur place dans quelques
jours ici c'est des ventes qui sort
d'aulnay par le par le tribunal de
commerce
ces entreprises qui sont en cessation
d'activité il y en a plusieurs centaines
par an sur le doubs et sur la franche
comté
donc c'est des entreprises qui ont qui
sont en défaut de paiement
donc on va vendre
le mieux possible et puis en même temps
et c'est de libérer les locaux le plus
rapidement possible pour surtout ne pas
aggraver la dette fixé des prix qu'ils
soient ceux du stock d'un commerçant
faillite ou d'un objet d'art c'est un
métier qui ne s'invente pas pour être
commissaire priseur il faut avoir fait
son droit mais aussi des études
d'histoire de l'art et savoir
s'émerveiller au quotidien quand on
prend un objet qu'on se dit oh là là
mais j'ai jamais vu ça avant
il ya un gars qui a eu la la créativité
pour inventer ça et en plus c'est beau
et ça et bien finalement c'est le petit
truc magique qui fait que d'un objet
quelquefois tout à fait courant et un
petit détail qui vous fait dire à ça
c'est beau jean paul renoux grappin et
commissaire priseur depuis 1991
comme son père et son grand père avant
lui une profession un peu mystérieuse
qu'il a su rendre accessible en ouvrant
sa selle des ventes au plus grand nombre